okay I'm finally in Israel of course to
understand today's Israel and the
surrounding territories you have to
understand its history this should only
take a minute
by 1300 BC settlers had created the
kingdoms of Israel and Judah who were
conquered by the Babylonians who were
conquered by the Greeks were conquered
by the Romans were conquered by the
Byzantines were conquered by the Arabs
who were conquered by the Crusaders were
conquered by the Ottomans who were
conquered by the British who helped the
dream of a Jewish homeland and were
supplanted by Jewish refugees fleeing
from Nazis who were given an insane map
for two new countries like the United
Nations followed by the declaration of
the State of Israel which led to a war
with Arab nations which led to thousands
of refugees a crisis with Egypt another
war with Arabs and occupation terrorism
Yasser Arafat another war with Arab USA
to Israel a settlement policy a peace
treaty a war with Lebanon a Palestinian
uprising the proposed peace treaty an
assassination that a Palestinian
uprising another war with Lebanon more
settlements more terrorism the
separation wall surging economic growth
negative economic growth moss and the
PLA versus Israel Hamas versus the PLA
Israeli Jews versus American Jews
Israeli Orthodox Jews versus Israeli
conservative Jews versus Israeli Reform
Jews Jewish and Arab man against Jewish
American and more settlements far
Refaeli the Israeli Gaza conflict is
real hitting a bomb is really loving
Trump it's really some Palestinians
confused by Jared Kushner and three of
the holiest sites in the world built on
top of each other plus Druze Bedouins
science and one Buddhist all setting the
table for a visit by me run on the bride
destroy make some people laugh and in
the process a lien on caprica
what hello everybody and welcome to the
Conan Israel live Q&A yes we are here
with Jose Arroyo Jesse Gaskell writers
on our show and of course Conan O'Brien
before we get started Conan has
something he wanted to say yes I wanted
to point out we have done many travel
shows one of my all-time favorites is
the show that we did in Mexico in Mexico
City
we made an incredible number of friends
there and that was a very important show
to us and obviously Mexico has been very
hard hit by a terrible earthquake and a
lot of people in Mexico City are
suffering right now this morning I
tweeted out some information if you're
interested in donating or looking for
any way to help I tweeted out some
information that might be useful and
maybe you could give that a look if you
could and just our thoughts and our
prayers are with the beautiful people of
Mexico right now and and we're thinking
of them oh I didn't realize you spoke
what did you say there did you say corn
is an idiot thank you for joining us
today and yes I mean you bring up a good
point
Mexico see this is our 7th Travel Show
we've done Israel's our seventh one it's
hard to believe Cuba Armenia Qatar Korea
Mexico City and Berlin and what are
right up top what are the challenges of
shooting in a place like Israel well
shooting in a lot of ways I think Israel
was is the most difficult because
clearly as you saw in that opening that
we wanted to make we wanted to very
quickly sum up how complex it is there
and there's a there's a misconception
that in Israel there are two points of
view and that there are two opposing
sides but we tried to set up in that in
that opening of the show was to educate
people that they're not two points of
view there are 65 or maybe a hundred and
six
five different points of view and it's a
very small land mass land area about the
size of I think new to the state of New
Jersey it's very small and you have a
lot of people there who feel very
intensely they feel their beliefs very
intensely and they disagree and there's
obviously been a whole history of
violence and there's a lot there that
there's a lot of conflict and we went
there and obviously the main goal is to
try and bring comedy to the situation
and basically just take it down to a
human level doing that in Israel and
threading the needle of trying to be
respectful to so many different points
of view was incredibly difficult it was
a real challenge and so I wanted to
start by giving it up for my team
Jose Jesse they've come on all the
travel shows he's sitting in the back
for me cos we don't understand Mike
Sweeney creators in the corn can't you
just come in and like edge of the chair
this doesn't have to look that nice Mike
Sweeney is I don't want to scare away
younger you know Mike Sweeney don't be
fooled kids he's only 28 could you want
a drug I mean early 2000s and so that's
why you know don't do drugs but this is
the team right here that goes with me
and they work incredibly hard and we
debated I think more than any other
episode we had intense debates about you
know how we should approach this what we
should do you know where we should go
and it was I think I'm very proud of the
fact that we're so honest with each
other and that we quarrel so much we
became a microcosm for the State of
Israel and then when it was done I think
it really created a product when I say I
hate the word product we created a show
that I feel as impossible it is
to encapsulate what's going on in Israel
in 40 minutes I thought we we gave
people a little bit of taste and and I
was very happy that one of the reactions
I heard the most from young people
especially young Americans was oh I I
didn't know some of that stuff right
they laughed really hard but they also
were intrigued and wanted to find out
more so I thought that was cool yeah Anu
Miura and Facebook said a great
condensed history lesson so there we go
they didn't know a lot of that stuff and
now they're learning see guys you can
learn stuff oh yeah yeah I've always
said if people learn something from
watching our show we're not doing our
job really we're supposed to be we're
supposed to be funny
yeah it's it on Facebook Matt first in
asked a very basic question to step back
and this is for these three guys right
here what are the challenges of shooting
in a remote location versus a studio and
we're talking very remote we're talking
about across the world what are the
first steps there how do we do it how do
we do it how does it work also it's a
really good this would be a good moment
not to instruct you guys how to answer
but fired if you don't follow my
instructions I think giving our props to
the now even now yes now we crew in
Israel would be a board so step one is
have a good ground crew of producers
we're in the country that you're going
to Asif and Rhoni ready if they were
then that the production company that we
used that now we people were now hiepro
yes now we pro they they were really
instrumental because Mike and was
talking to them right away long quite a
while before we made the trip right Mike
and you know Jason and Jason Jason show
let's give our props to Jason and the
Warriors yeah Jason was the one dealing
with them Jason is always the frontman
with with our local producers and he
every show we've done he always gets
you're just like wow these they're
amazing they know everything they
facilitate everything and and we make
stuff up as we go and we always have
these teams that that are just right
there with us and yeah
how many sensibilities yeah yes the more
you prepare ahead of time the yeah you
can adjust to the things that are going
to come up inevitably right changes of
schedule or availability well they also
just tell you you know we didn't know I
think also people in Israel were stunned
while we were is really just kept saying
the same thing
Conan's everywhere and I think what
accustomed to is maybe a celebrity stops
in if they stop in at all and they come
to Tel Aviv and they make a few TV
appearances to promote whatever they're
doing then they're gone
and every time it was covered a lot in
in the Israeli press but I was just I
was constantly in a completely different
part of the country that is always is a
guy the size of New Jersey the size of
New Jersey we know a couple three hour
bus rides hours on the bus and and and
just sort of going through the desert
and every now and then I'd nod off on
the bus and then wake up and look out
the window and you'd see camels and and
so it was I I think the fact that we had
going in prepared is so important and
all of us also tried to educate
ourselves as much as possible we read
histories of Israel we read different
histories of Israel I was reading some
Israeli fiction just trying to immerse
myself in some of the issues I talked to
friends who are very passionate I talked
to friends that are passionate on
different sides and so the more you can
immerse yourself in that before you go
yeah
so when you go into the country you're
not going in cold I think that would be
the biggest mistake to just show up ago
what's this is real place where can I
get a sandwich you know that would be
would be stupid and you had never been
there before had anyone has anyone been
to Israel before this trip yeah so what
surprised you guys about about it like
when you got there you know your
preconceived notions versus what it's
actually like what was the biggest you I
would say you kind of mentioned everyone
was camera-ready that everyone was very
it's true that they but in Tel Aviv I
they take their Sabbath very seriously I
thought that was a you know a
fascinating thing the store shut down
then after a certain period at sundown
the stores would reopen and and that was
just par for the course their Sunday is
our Monday so the way it changes the
culture is very exactly is that day is
ours yes exactly exactly I go through
every day of the week there Wednesday
again strangely there Wednesday is our
Sunday of course you know this is their
seventh show we've done so we've spent a
lot of time together kylie nelson from
facebook asks what's the best
behind-the-scenes story from israel
there's always things that don't make
the show because we're not filming a lot
of time my favorite is well there's a
lot from there's a lot of great moments
from this one but my favorite is that I
wear a mic all the time when I'm
shooting because what happens is
something everything you so many of the
great moments that you saw in the show
have they really happen like the old man
I bump into David who ends up taking
them to his apartment that just happened
we bumped into him and then I said let's
go and we went up to his apartment one
of the reasons I think that's so funny
to people is that you can tell it's
really happening you can't you can't
create a moment like that they just
happen so that means I need to be miked
all the time and we usually have to have
cameras rolling we were in the bus and I
had my microphone on and everyone here
all of the producers have these little
headsets that they wear so that they can
hear what I'm saying if I'm talking to
people on camera jokes or suggesting yes
now like listening to code but I will
say this I always assumed that when I'm
not shooting and say we're on the bus
chilling you wouldn't be listening Jose
was not on our bus and we all like to
make us on the bus behind him yes
comes in and I start just making random
jokes about Jose Jose so fussy yeah yeah
Taiyo he's probably in the back eating a
tiny pair reputation I have these jokes
that I do advise to say about how euro
he is fussy and he's always you know
fastidious and he's very always neatly
dressed in his and so I was just doing I
think fairly my harmless routine about
Jose when it's related to me that Jose's
listening to all of this tell Conan I
can hear everything yeah and then they
had a single tear but anyway that was
fun but I would say there were so many
give a shout-out to our crew wires we
are warriors that st. Vincent James pal
Chesky and Jason Munoz Jason does the
audio for us he always and we're all
when we go in these like will go into
these tiny spaces that are ancient and
we're like Bulls in a china shop because
we have all this equipment and we're
these style yes yeah and so jason has
his giant boom mic that he's always kind
of like whipping around quickly
following Conan when a boom mic just
make sure people understand it's a long
stick with what looks like a cylindrical
furry mop at the end you know dust you
know a duster it looks like something
that you would Dustin tougher but a
Swiffer yeah at the end and he yeah
imagine that almost like a giant fuzzy
thing at the end
so anyway continue around like this
inside the Church of the Nativity where
Jesus is rumored to have been born yeah
I'm gonna get later spat and we just
suddenly hear a clatter and we look over
and Jason is covered in oil from these
lamps that are hanging really
like centuries-old lamps and he's now
drenched in oil all over the floor and I
don't I think several people who might
have died so the the it was the manger
yes believe it or not isn't very big
yeah it's where you know site of for the
site of Christ's birth and they it's
also terrifying I've had many occasions
where we've been in a sort of sacred
site and you can see new nose walking
through with his boom and it's always
just missing like the Mona Lisa you know
like this priceless work of art that
everyone's put a lot of thought into how
to present it and you know it's always
trying to hit justice I'm gonna say I
love him I love him it's not the most
he's always got like nine packs and he's
sweating and he's adjusting levels and
this stick is waving around crazily it
was just miss you know the Statue of
David around and almost hit the Venus de
Milo and it's your hearts in your mouth
we shouldn't be allowed you know it's
Craig diver from Facebook ass and we get
this question literally every time you
do a live Q&A so let's just get it out
of the way it's this do we have sex with
each other
no where is Jordan where is Jordan
during all this let's just get this out
of the way where is Jordan when we were
in Israel people believe it or not every
country we go to people's people I don't
care where we are people are like where
is Jordan and arctica and you know it's
always Germany that is you know there's
everyone wants to know where Jordan is
have you were joking about we actually
thought about this before yes we're like
well visit the Dead Sea and on the other
side the Dead Sea is the border between
Israel and in parts the West Bank and
Jordan that's so we were gonna have to
gonna go you know on this side I'm in
Israel there's the Dead Sea and if you
pan the camera you can see Jordan and we
were going to fly Jordan a
on the other side of course looking
looking like a self-satisfied ass and
they're like yeah you know we're gonna
bring Jordan on on a travel show that
makes sense
most Centanni go yeah why do you want to
bring them on one because I think the
fans want it so badly it just has to be
it has to be the perfectly right or
perfectly wrong fist yes and we also
know that if we take Jordan and I'm not
even kidding about this the you know we
have to try and be cost-effective on
these things are somewhat responsible
the the bill for Jordan all insists on
eating the finest foods and I'm not even
kidding about this so we're sometimes
kind of down and dirty just hitting a
restaurant and whatever having the local
gold star beer and and you know having
some quick Mediterranean food and on the
run he will have found I mean the
restaurant we have to go to and he'll
make sure that we order the most
expensive wines put a lot of thought
into it and then we won't have money to
like edit the show actually David
Grotowski ass gold star or Maccabee i'ma
cut Maccabi how do you say it Maccabee
macadamia I'm a gold star get gold stars
because I get a commercial forum and I
understand I want my money I'm not a
gold star hey gold star I paid you guys
a solid that's it there should be some
form of repayment we can talk about what
that is out there
Sweeny brought up the Dead Sea we went
to the Dead Sea which was an amazing
experience
now coning you cover yourself in mud did
the mud really make a difference on your
skin oh look I probably didn't leave it
on long enough
right it's you're supposed to feel
amazing afterwards yes I I'm not the
most in tune with my body I have a lot
of body shame and I grew up very
Catholic so ya know I don't notice
things about my body you could take a
piece of my body off and I probably
wouldn't know for several years so I
didn't notice anything but people swear
by that mud you guys did the mud too
right yeah
so what did you guys think what did you
guys think didn't make your skin
smoother did it felt it sort of smoothed
out your skin I don't know there was
something and what was it like for
people who haven't been to the Dead Sea
what is it like being in what does it
feel like crazy you can slip it feels
oily on on you it's so viscous knock out
past a certain point without floating
like your legs will kick out Bob right
yes yes yeah but you're not allowed to
swallow the water or get it in your eyes
so it's very relaxed yeah but again I
met a very attractive woman there and
that's right I you know I'm just saying
if you're single I think Dead Sea I mean
I was floating in the dead seat for 30
seconds and then when I noticed a very
attractive woman
everything and you know I put the moves
on her again still batting zero no they
told me you have to take your wedding
ring off because it would well I I think
it's so salty that it would tarnish the
the gold and so it's this kind of
interesting thing with it like remove
your wedding ring go in and here's some
ladies in bikinis and I'm just saying it
comes a little like a setup to me that's
right another reason to go the Dead Sea
is they say will it's drying up a few
meters a year right that's the metric
system
it'll be on and like I don't know
because 3,000 and it's actually it's man
it's man-made
I mean Betsy isn't man-made but the
crisis they the crisis is man-made
because waters been diverted using these
different dams and so it's it's losing
and you can you can actually witness
when you're there they show you oh the
beach used to be here but now it's 25
feet that way so they were saying
yeah Galilee by the way Sea of Galilee
we went to the Sea of Galilee and I did
an enter an interview there Alfie the
the host of high humble Isla yeah kind
of The Tonight Show of Israel yeah nice
okay good hurtful why not the Conan show
of Israel the Conan he always brings up
the Tonight Show just like Conan it's a
night show in Israel I know Guri is a
young okay Curry's a joy Blais last
appearance no gory is a really funny
comedian and so we shot a thing it's a
really funny idea where that I did for
his show in Israel where we're both you
just see our heads floating in the Sea
of Galilee and he was so much fun to
riff with and and to improv with and I'm
sure that's going to be up somewhere
that interview because it's really funny
and how my god again you know you're
getting on this role and we're looking
behind you him the boat got the anchor
came up from the mud or something and it
was just 40 yards away our sound guy who
knows I don't know it because it's
behind me but only suddenly I see these
three are laughing and holding them and
I thought I'm being funny right now I
think but I'm not being that funny and I
thought what what did I is it am I
making a funny face today and then I
read one of them gestures behind me and
I look and you nose and are with it what
the sound equipment in a boat has
drifted probably like a quarter-mile
away and we had to stop taping and get
him to come back and he's like what are
you I thought you guys move we didn't
move yeah and somehow on the way back
the boom that he was carrying smashed
three Ming vases Eileen from facebook
says eighty-seven point 68 of happiness
as my life is directly derived from
Conan I think that's how much happiness
is derived from Jason Munoz for
yeah seeing him there's another can she
do it could you do the math why don't we
take a second and say that's a nice
compliment and thank you very much and
that you only you know I we put a lot of
work into making the the show itself and
then these travel shows and the nightly
show and so when I meet people who get
pleasure out of what we're doing it
means every it means everything to me
because we we put a ton of effort into
this absolutely and actually call
territorial from YouTube says when we
visit Portugal all those tourists
already miss you there's a lot of
comments some of those Portugal tourists
yeah this alum are in the chat watching
if you want to say hi oh we know what is
how do you say hello in Portuguese I
don't say hello in Portuguese I made
contact us quickly it was so much fun to
just keep saying oh and and since then
if I keep running into people people
keep coming up to me this has happened a
number of times in the last week and a
half where people have come up to me and
it happened in London I was just in
London shooting something that I think
you're gonna see in a couple of days
that I very excited about more on that
later but I was in London and shooting
something just a couple days ago and
people have blunt and were coming up to
me saying I'm Portuguese and I just want
to say ah yes there are people that had
seen what I guess because you live
stream yeah yeah so and the other thing
is when we were in London we finished
shooting and we went into a pub and this
British guy who's I want to say 30 years
old in a pub in some nondescript part of
London I walk in and he said hey Conan I
thought you were in Tel Aviv for Conan
without boundaries and I say this
without borders
when I'm around yeah when I'm around
women on the staff
that's the Cinemax show yeah that's a
sin of X and of course you can you can
watch all those live streams they're
still up on our Facebook page and
because you're probably watching this
right now this live stream that's right
cameras here I'm here and a triplet I
decide to let him go through but I don't
realize there's about six and there are
they're all from Portugal little
Portuguese and they're all in the same
cruise boat and I'm like hello hello
sorry yes and there I'm like where
you're from Portugal so there's about
maybe 15 solid minutes of me going
boom like an I Love Lucy episode what
was that experience like Jose and Jesse
shooting in those markets we went and
shot I think - what kind of man of the
street things in markets like that what
was that like and what were some of the
challenges of shooting in that
environment hyper we're not breaking
things
Conan would always stop right in front
of like a tiny miniature glass I'm like
making sure the cameras also don't whip
around and hit people in the head
yes yeah it was really it was really
tight it was so claustrophobic when
you're doing the haggling thing and you
were concentrating on it and but but
it's just a sea of people walking by we
looked and the patriarchy for the
Eastern Orthodox religion Wow was being
shepherded through and he was around
this big and it looked as all to some of
the buildings and where we're trying to
get your to like it was just - it's
Christmas too much I mean these some of
these streets were designed thousands of
years ago before the advent of the
remote shoe really didn't they got to
think that through
when designing a city make sure it's
wide enough a wiseass and his camera
crew before it's giving birth to the
savior the Savior should have known
should have said very Kaplan You Tube
want to know where is the Alabama shop
was that in that's in in Jerusalem it's
right there in one of the shopping areas
and we rounded a corner and there it is
and it makes its all roll tide
go Alabama but it's it's it's in Hebrew
you're wonderful and I was I said to
them like you couldn't possibly them
like we do a very good I guess the owner
is someone who had gone to Alabama and
will then you have to openers most
people to be fair when they graduate
from that school say it's time to go to
Jerusalem our tour for Facebook has a
great complement happy Tel Aviv was
glowing and roaring with laughter the
whole time that's nice it's good and
also uh you know John Sawyer from
Facebook brings up a good question where
did you want to visit but didn't get to
I mean we went all over the country but
there's so many places to see we hit we
were planning to do a shoot at a kibbutz
where you'd really get to see me and I
could be iconic like I wanted to be
pushing a plow strumming a guitar and a
campfire milking and goats and we got I
think it was planned for later in the
trip and this happens but you start to
hit you had to really just hit a wall of
like I can't I don't know if like
physically ate that was like day eight
and it's it's you know 108 degrees and
now it's time for you to push a plow and
you know it'll be maybe we'll use it and
maybe we want
yeah and they're been just wow there
have been times like it to do the IDF
when I trained with the Israeli women
that in shoot involved me really doing
the obstacle course that that they all
have to do to be that eighteen year old
just seventeen year olds and eighteen
year olds do to get into the you know
Israeli army I'm no spring chicken and
it's just it's like that would do that
Conan does that and sometimes the
writers come to me the way we have an
idea what is it
Conan Minds for lead or for a day and we
shoot it and I'm like what do I just you
learn how to mine for let or and you
haul it out of the mines and then we'll
try it off it's funny will use it if not
what's the fun like how about salt in
the mud and of course you know we don't
we should have done more than we use so
you were you were already exhausted and
then we go get in there and get working
out that was an example of you know
debts here you're looking into Jordan
and then we drove an hour and a half and
random we're right near the Egyptian
border and yeah yeah yeah and then we're
up near Syria and I of all the border
I was curious to go near Lebanon as well
just it's yeah crazy that you're boarded
by there's also more you wanna we go to
these countries and then you want to go
back because there's a way that you're
experiencing them when you're shooting
is when you're doing these shows which
is so work focused and we're working all
the time and then we do take breaks but
you're constantly looking for what did
we get how would we what could we get
next how could we do this and this is a
trip where I thought I'm gonna come back
here and be a tourist and yes I too I
wanted I want to go back to Jerusalem I
would spend a week in drew I mean we had
we our schedule was so tight that we did
as we did to do a speak to our Jerusalem
I'm a just amazing it is sometimes it's
the travel equivalent of we're being
served a nine-course meal by a five-star
famous world famous French chef and
we're just really good I think I ate it
so fast there's so much pressure right
and so I'd like to go back sometime and
and and really really be there yeah I I
did that we we went to Berlin and then
did a show there and yes it's same thing
like were we there and then I had to go
my wife had to go their business I went
back with her on a week off a month
later and that's like this is I really
felt like I got to enjoy it
oh holy obviously a whole different way
right of course of course uh and so
Jenna Mohini from Facebook is asking do
the people of Israel know who you were I
think I can answer that with a number of
selfies you took on this trip I do think
I may have broken a record for self yes
I am known for I'm very tolerant of
selfies and I kind of stick out yeah I
mean people people never think I might
be someone else they know exactly who I
am and they want a selfie but yeah you
know what you said during an interview
there by the way I will yes I did I will
give you a selfie and of course people
wanted a selfie I was surprised
well two things a lot of so many people
in that he said when I was on an NBC in
the late-night show that they showed it
for a good period of time in Israel oh
so there are a lot of people I met who
were now like in their 30s and they're
like no I I grew up watching you
someone's home ah I keep meeting people
who say I learned English like you or
how I learned English which i think is
tragic but also i think it's a testament
to this world we live in now where are
the you know our show the the Turner
show doesn't air there right like they
I mean so many people who know us from
the way you're experiencing us right now
they see they see stuff online and that
makes me happy like I said I was just in
London in this little rich boy he looked
like you know he had just come from
inheriting Willy Wonka's chocolate
factory waking up to me it was like are
you Conan I have a photo with you and
and I said well sure our little English
boy I'm like putting my arm around him
to take a selfie and his mother said he
watches you every day on YouTube he's
always watching walking about town and I
thought well that's great that makes me
a bad guy and then I said I'll give you
a lift in my lorry and they said but I
was saying as a credit to you and and
everyone here and apologies from all of
us in the digital team it's become
almost doing a second show because we
are constantly filming you filming so
you know that what I like about that I
mean yes are you annoying is Ruthie
annoying
Ruthie's always coming up to me
everything's back there Ruthie Ruthie
obviously more than anybody else Ruthie
will I will just have done something
where the these guys said hey would be
really funny if you push that Boulder up
to the top the Golan Heights we may use
it it's funny Norville so I do it in a
110 degree heat and I get to the top and
they're like it'd look pretty good
not sure we're gonna use it but thanks
again I'm drenched in sweat and just and
that's always when Ruthie comes up and
goes hey four flicks net dot jorb I can
use it a thing where you you look at the
camera and you talk for ten minutes and
make a lot of jokes about what you just
did does this air on TV no does it go on
the internet sort of it's more gas seen
by me you know and so god bless her
she's always coming up to me sort of
like someone who's been told you have to
poke that old bear and she looks scared
but you know what's really what's nice
is that there's sort of two lives to
these shows now because so many people
followed us in Israel because of what
bleh and Ruthie were doing and and our
digital team it's really nice because in
a way the show began when we started
when we went to Israel for the first
time and started to make it it used to
be the old days you'd go off and shoot
something and in the vid be this voila
finally that it's done and take a look
and now it's I think kind of beautiful
is that it starts when we're there and
so many people you saw opponents here
he's there he's you know this is
happening I had so many people saw that
Dead Sea photo of me reading the Israeli
newspaper yeah that that the narrative
begins there and then the show is the
finished product but there's a whole
story that unfolds in between which i
think is neat yeah absolutely it's kind
of a companion piece to the actual show
like the and the notes in the margins
Ruthie Cosette pull your shirt back
people are seeing some that's another
thing too is this I am NOT a guy who
wants people to see me without a shirt I
have the appropriate level of shame that
I should have about my I didn't get into
comedy because I was a killer looking
guy they keep having ad everywhere we go
they're like ok be really funny you were
completely naked except for a small
piece of cloth you know people don't
want to see this like it'll be good it's
a funny way to plough yeah exactly
it should plow wearing this Maternity
foam nothing else so I apologize I am
NOT they keep coming up with things
where it's like Conan takes off his
shirt and slowly gets into caramel it's
a pseudonym bad lighting from 8 angles
caramel I'm Megan from a Tupac Megan for
Facebook Megan I want to say her last
name
taboc will licky that's amazing name
says you spoke about eating just a few
moments ago what was the best thing you
ate what was everybody's favorite food
we ate a lot of food explain also kind
of these trips where people just kind of
we sit and people kind of bring us their
bring us just these countries there's no
ordering especially in Israel there so
like there they were they knew we were
there see us come in and see the Freak
and his posse is maybe it's past here
here sit sit then they'd be like and I'd
sit like you know maybe I'd see
something I kind of wanted no I might
have the chicken nuggets
no-ho-ho chicken nuggets for you we're
bringing you all of our most exotic
dishes it's the octopus eye that's
soaked in brine and they start coming in
but yes it's amazing fish and you know
to say the hummus was really good is
stupid business sounds it sounds too
obvious but it's so pretty right it was
written
I also had but there are other things
too I had it was one man I think we got
pasta and I was like this is amazing
pasta and it wasn't so there are nights
where you are eating something oh we
went to a like a Thai restaurant in Tel
Aviv yes it was excellent Thai food and
that has happened a bunch of times to
where you think we're only going to be
eating the food that would be on the
tourism bureau of ocean instead where
we're at a really really good Burger
King that's a kosher perfect answer
there was something that happened during
dinner I hate to bring it up Jerusalem
does anyone want an address where Jose
might have disappeared oh well we had
shot all day yes very hot day and we
always hey Jose we all worked equally
hard and then all of us were supposed to
meet for dinner for dinner and we all
were there but in my Rouge is my hotel
to get up for dinner and we're little
European alarm clock yes it's made of
the bakelite it has made of Mars it's
been through this so I set my alarm and
then I hit the snooze and I went back to
sleep and then I suddenly wake up to a
half a dozen texts where are you are you
ok people but I haven't wandered off
into the streets of Jerusalem by myself
and they were worried for me because I
no one was worried worried I was worried
I thank you yeah so I panicked and I
thought Oh as a joke I'm gonna go to the
restaurant and appear in my bathroom
because I thought that it was just a
little place of 30 people or so and it
turns out that the restaurant was huge
it's at about 200 million it's very
fancy it's a super fancy
clintons eaten there and I show up with
my gag I put on a robe it'll be
hilarious he came into a country that's
known a lot of trauma he can't get us
again doing his gag
I'm sad a lot of people comedy yeah I
heard the last go from with me to at me
and then I had to commit to the bit for
the rest of the dinner we don't think
they're sleeping or drawing or or what's
my weakness so yeah yes but anyway I did
show up to one of the fanciest
restaurants in Jerusalem in a bathrobe
fortunately I've met they're letting me
live it down so if there are any
unsolved murders from that evening look
for terrycloth
I know Cohen asked speaking of looking
sexy Coney gal gadot teach you Krav Maga
she did not okay
she did not how did that come about how
did the gal gadot thing come about we
know we we shot we actually shot a piece
together before Wonder Woman came out
there liked that was a lot of fun she is
an absolute dream as a person just a
lovely person and completely unaffected
by how this you know Wonder Woman has
made her you know arguably the biggest
female star in the world and so we we
sort of suggested hey we knew that she
was in Tel Aviv would you want to do a
quick thing on the show I bought 80%
chance now that she right now is Wonder
Woman that she'd probably want a little
downtime I wouldn't do it she said yes
love to do it and she and her people set
up the whole thing and I show up and she
she was like gonna get any requests
melee or no one
really hurt cuz yeah but it's easy to
get lost at how incredibly beautiful she
is and but just talking with her and
working with her she's you would never
know you would never know that this
woman is now you know like the most
bankable star in the world yeah and the
head of this really cool new franchise
and I do have to say of all the things
that I have done I got more street cred
from my daughter all I did was take it
it was send to the selfie of me with and
and go and sent it off to to my daughter
and she just wrote back all caps
exclamation point OMG you know it went
on and on and on and on so I owe her for
and I was we were so thrilled that she
yea played a part in it and of course as
always I'm the creep who strikes out and
she's the patient beautiful woman who
can't wait to shut the door I was she
was so funny and improvising I think we
only really did one take with her we did
one time yeah it was it I mean it was
just she knew no she knew exactly yeah
he's been hit on she has spent a
lifetime trying to close the door you
know exact she knew exactly what to do
there the sense-memory
yeah I think we'll have time for just a
few more questions but here's a one to
maybe start the wrap up from Arianna
Lingenfelter from Facebook my favorite
thing about laughter comedy is that it
is such an international language do you
find that everybody laughs at similar
things or do you have to change it
depending on where you are Jose do you
want to start with that I think this we
always go in with Conan as a fish out of
water and trying to get his bearings in
a new place and people there are so
eager to help him that that the comedy
comes from him trying and failing and
there are some Universal things I think
I think there are many I think there are
more Universal things than not than not
actly mining iron ore with a language
barrier right you're sort of resorting
to sort of the language behind the
language right Jess protects an effort
you know we saw this I mean with the
first show in Cuba there were so many
people that they didn't know they don't
know who I am they don't know what I'm
all about but my my happiest moments are
one of them were in the cigar factory in
Cuba right or whether I'm in a you know
talking to a rug merchant in Armenia or
you know whether I'm in South Korea just
talking to some you know older people I
run into on the street there are all
these moments where they don't speak the
language they don't know who I am but if
I can get them to laugh I just I I it's
what's bye it's sublime it's my happiest
those are my happiest moments because
there's all these universal things and
one thing that I've noticed that people
love over and over and over again is me
trying something and then getting sad
you know American audiences have been
watching me do that for you know twenty
four years now just getting real
enthusiastic and then realizing it
didn't work and just becoming
crestfallen and looking sad and and
losing confidence having confidence and
losing confidence and I've noticed that
that's kind of universal like it doesn't
matter where I am they're like that man
he was so confident and then it didn't
work out and he's laughing you know
and and and finally I mean of course
whenever we do one of these live Q&A s
one of the questions we get the most is
where are you going next where are you
going next where are you going next
Iceland in the Russia all these people
are wanting to know Singapore it's just
the questions are pouring in any idea
where we're going down he's had a joke
we were joking we were joking that
Israel was some was so much work you got
it to try and get it right and to try
and be sensitive to so much and to try
and it's been such a chore that we've
been saying like the next ones that the
fourth you know Four Seasons Resort on
Maui yeah for a month we don't shoot
them Conan gets a deep tissue massage
Juiz didn't we realized we're still the
United States we loved pretty much every
place you mentioned would be a place I'd
love to go so we don't know we don't and
and this is like today is the first time
we've been able to relax because we were
editing this show now these guys were
editing this show up until the last
second last night and feeding it unless
we nee had to run it to your homes
[Laughter]
you're seeing us the next day waking up
realizing that's over and you know we're
not I can't even begin to imagine
thinking about the next step
at least until 47 when I could depend on
news and if something I don't know
something bigs happening in the world
somewhere Trump decides to build another
wall somewhere Conan will find a
challenge yeah Conan has a masochistic
streak and I'm out of his punch range so
I can say that but he likes to he likes
to challenge himself Oh
it really does look like Jose is
pleading with his relatives with the
ransom money being treated well but they
have a good cause always looking for a
challenge no I do I probably have a
masochistic streak but I I do sometimes
go someplace we don't make a funny show
we don't really work that hard and
somehow we trick Turner into paying for
just a lot of room service and a lot of
us just like did you sleep well you know
I hope Turner's not watch me they don't
there they're not what I'll tell you is
watching Jordan Parsons on Facebook sis
Bigelow how do the whole crew from a
whole lot we said Maui beautiful I think
so before we kind of wrap things up you
know is there something you want to say
to everyone we met you know in Israel
the people we met above there and the
West Bank a message for the people
watching at home either in Israel or not
in Israel about our trip I think it
would be important to know that there's
a lot of speculation because it's such a
divisive place that the minute we
arrived in Israel that was I think there
was some paper that said oh Cohn is
being paid by the Israeli government to
come here and show for the Israeli
government not true I mean I wish they
said we were getting money up I would
kill for that money if someone left
money for me there was a lot of
speculation I think when we went to you
know the West Bank or people say well
why is he going there there's there's a
there's a lot of hot-button topics there
and I didn't want people to know very
sincerely
our intention was to go and to really
try and keep it simple
neat people try and make them laugh make
friends make friends with Israelis make
friends with Arabs and try and find
common ground through just things that
we can universally find funny
and that was our there was nothing else
and obviously they're gonna be certain
people out there that want to read in
some kind of intention and as honestly
as I can say we really did go there too
to try and make people happy make people
laugh and when I watched the show last
night I thought oh wait I think we I
think we did that and so that makes me
very happy so I wanted to say to you
know people who ever we met whoever we
talked to thank you for being so warm so
welcoming to us and getting such great
improv partners whether it was in Tel
Aviv or the West Bank or Jerusalem
everybody was so open to to us and to
playing along playing with us and also
you know occasionally telling us really
how they felt about things and I thought
that was a beautiful experience
absolutely so thank you to everybody and
thank you to youtube and facebook for
joining us thank you everybody and thank
you that's right get flicks that John
fedora and also Ruthie wants to fly it's
a new startup and all they need me to do
is work really hard lifting weights that
becomes a liquid that's six people see
Jose gets last word to camera thank you
awesome
Brody Nev and everyone is out of course
and you can go to a team koco.com slash
israel to see a whole host of extras
including night time in java ways remote
and all sorts of other cool and a quick
other shout out yes the show foul des
it's on net always and the people who
make the show foul it is an amazing show
if you like the wire basically if you
just are a fan of really well told drama
this is an amazing story that actually i
think tells actually portrays the
conflicting feelings and emotions that
exist in israel very well and without
good guy bad guy and it's a beautiful
show foul de you should really watch it
and i did I get a guest spot on that and
I think it's gonna be become a thing
here in America and I'm encouraging
people to watch it because check out
that first season you can binge watch it
and you will not be able to stop it you
will not be disappointed
and finally Conan I did a bar mitzvah
and you can win one of these boys a man
shirts on Facebook for a chance to in
two minutes
you know you this that's me you're gonna
be the only one that has this that's
exactly and thank you again to everybody
watching
thank you everyone to who everyone we
met over there and we will see you very
soon gun is real cheap okay thank you
guys
you